THE SOLE FACTOR THAT GOES INTO
THEM.
AND THAT CAN BE A CHALLENGING
THING TO COMMUNICATE.
HAVING THE SEPARATION WILL BE
VERY VALUABLE.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THIS
LATEST CONFUSING GUIDANCE I HAVE
TO SAY ON WHETHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE TESTED POSITIVE SHOULD
GET A COVID TEST BEFORE THEY
LEAVE ISOLATION -- ISOLATION
WENT DOWN FROM 10 DAYS TO 5 -- I
HAVE TO SAY THIS PART ISN'T
NECESSARILY HER FAULT.
THEY WERE ASKED, CDC WAS ASKED,
SHOULD SOMEBODY TAKE A TEST AND
CDC ULTIMATELY SAID, WELL,
THAT'S UP TO YOU.
BUT THE TRUTH IS WE HAVE A
TESTING SHORTAGE.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TESTS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT'S NOT DR. WALENSKY'S
FAULT.
THAT'S THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE'S
THEY PROMISED THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE TESTS EVERYWHERE
FOR EVERYONE WHENEVER WE NEEDED
THEM AND WE'RE NOT THERE.
AND YOU YOURSELF HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE FRUSTRATIONS OF
THAT SHORTAGE.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT PART OF THIS
IS ALSO WALENSKY TAKING BLAME
FOR BIDEN BLUNDERS?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IF WE WERE
IN A SITUATION, JAKE, WHERE
THERE WAS AN UNLIMITED SUPPLY OF
TESTS, WE PROBABLY WOULD SAY,
YOU KNOW, REDUCE TO FIVE DAYS
AND TEST COMING OUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT SOMEONE IS STILL ISN'T
POSITIVE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE IN.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
HAVE TESTS TO DETERMINE UP FRONT
WHO TRULY HAS COVID.
AND SO WITHOUT THAT, I THINK
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT OUTCOME.
THE CHALLENGE IS THAT WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS, WELL, OKAY, BUT
WHAT IF I DO TEST, WHAT DO I DO?
AND THE GUIDANCE COMING OUT WAS,
WELL, THEN YOU SHOULD PROBABLY
CONTINUE TO STAY IN ISOLATION
FOR ANOTHER FIVE DAYS.
THAT LEADS TO VERY MIXED
MESSAGING.
BUT I THINK YOUR POINT IS RIGHT.
IF THERE WAS AN UNLIMITED SUPPLY
OF TESTS, WHAT WOULD WE DO?
I THINK WE WOULD ASK PEOPLE TO
TEST TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE
NEGATIVE COMING OUT.
THE CRITICAL PIECE THERE, THOUGH
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE MOST
CONTAGIOUS EARLY ON AND WITH
EACH DAY AFTER THAT, THE
LIKELIHOOD OF YOU TRANSMITTING
WILL GO DOWN.
AND SO SOME PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE
TO TRANSMIT, BUT MOST PEOPLE
AFTER FIVE DAYS WILL NOT.
>> ANYONE ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
ESPECIALLY TWITTER, KNOWS THE
CDC HAS BECOME THE BUTT OF A LOT
OF JOKES OVER THE LAST WEEK.
THERE'S A SERIES OF MEMES,
JOKING ABOUT WHAT THE CDC MIGHT
RECOMMEND NEXT.
AN EXAMPLE MIGHT BE THAT WE'VE
SEEN THAT THE CDC SAYS, YOU CAN
NOW RUN WITH SCISSORS OR THERE'S
ANOTHER TWEET ALSO RESONATING
WITH A LOT OF FOLKS THAT
CAPTURED THE FRUSTRATION OF THE
MOMENT.
QUOTE, STAY INDOORS BUT ALSO
RETURN IN PERSON, WEAR A MASK,
NOT THAT ONE, THE EXPENSIVE ONE
THAT YOU CAN'T FIND, TAKE RAPID
TESTS WHICH YOU CAN'T FIND BUT
IF YOU FIND ONE, DON'T BUY THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WORK.
YOU NEED PCR.
THERE ARE ZERO APPOINTMENTS IN
YOUR AREA, UNQUOTE.
YOU WORKED AT THE CDC.
HOW DID JOKES LIKE THAT LAND
INSIDE THE BUILDING?
>> I THINK THEY STING.
THE CURRENT CDC DIRECTOR
INHERITED A SITUATION THAT I
WOULDN'T WISH ON MY WORST ENEMY.
AND THAT'S COMING IN IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC AFTER A
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE PUBLIC
HEALTH WAS VILIFIED, PUBLIC
HEALTH WAS LIFTED UP AS THE
BARRIER TO THE END OF THE
PANDEMIC, AS THE ENEMY OF OUR
ECONOMY.
AND SO COMING INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THE NATION IS POLARIZED
AND TRYING TO REASSERT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOLLOWING THE PATH
OF PUBLIC HEALTH, IT WAS AN
UNTHINKABLE CHALLENGE TO BE
ADDRESSING.
AND WE'RE SEEING HOW HARD THAT
ACTUALLY IS.
I HOPE COMING OUT OF THIS, AS A
NATION, WE'RE COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS.
OUR FEDERAL SYSTEM, OUR STATE,
OUR LOCAL.
AS YOU'VE SEEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADERS HAVE LEFT BECAUSE
OF H